so I'm an architect @jeremy oh and
formerly i was at twitter the tech lead
and that's where we created the park in
collaboration with Herrera at the time
you know we had the vertical which is a
good database distributed database and
Hadoop and vertical scale doesn't scale
as much as I do but Hadoop is not as
responsive as a vertical so the idea was
to make Hadoop more of database and less
of a file system so it's kind of the
premise to parking i'm also an Apache
member and right now I've been
contributed to arrow Park hey and I'm
also on the incubator in ppm c so today
I'll start with talking about you know
how to build community different
standards like parque and arrow the
importance of interpret interoperability
and to build an ecosystem because it's
not only about building cool technology
or having something that's efficient for
particular task it's also about how you
make all those things work together
right you don't just have a bunch of
libraries that you can use it's also bad
having all those tools and systems
working together well and so in
particular for parking arrow I'll talk
about the benefits of culinary our
presentation explain the why we do it
that way and then I'll talk about the
future and what we're headed to so first
I'll talk about the community driven
standard how do you get there so when we
started parque there was a common need
for a columnar format a good columnar
format for Hadoop stuff and not
necessarily only Hadoop but all the big
data ecosystem that goes with it and
some people are using it without HDFS or
in s three hours or distributed file
system and so we started looking into it
and I was looking at the Dremel paper
and trying to implement some of the kind
of high-level details that are not very
explained in the paper and and at the
time we didn't really want this to be a
proprietary format right it was not very
good it's good to have good technology
but then if you have to integrate it
with every single things you're going to
use going to be a huge cost so we
started i was at twitter at the time so
i started tweeting about it and still
tweet but you know with good motivation
to start that way and we connected with
the impala team at the time from career
and themselves they were looking for a
good columnar format and they were
starting experimenting so I had a
prototype they have the prototype so we
met and we put our effort together and
that was good because i was starting
something that was more community it was
not just one company it was more than
one and we're kind of starting building
a consensus on how this should work and
we were bringing more for java side of
seeing things and they were employees in
c++ native code so they were bringing
the C++ side of things of seeing things
and we were trying to build the database
from the ground up right we are looking
at the forum at first and they were
building a query engine so they were
bringing also like actual integration
way with the query imaging from the
start so that was a good you know
working together that was a good start
and so we started collaborating on
making parquet and then as and starting
to talk about it and do all this at some
point you know other teams started talk
with us so the drill team came and one
of the important point was to be very
open and very weak welcoming to other
people to say hey what do you need oh
you have this use case we need to do
those types and integrate that into the
spec and it's a difficult balance
because you want to support like other
people use case but as a standard format
you don't want to add too many bells and
whistles because more complexity is a
more thing there in it the less likely
it is to be like widely adopted and we
started from that so I
impala i used it and then drill used it
and then the spark people started using
it so sparks equal using Sparky as well
as its native most efficient format
ended they didn't even contact you this
where they just did it and then at that
point it started spreading and it became
like de facto standard for columnar
formats rights amazing I mean I work
hard you kind of tried to evangelize
adventure lies and make it work but it
really did work and it's a good you know
it's the combination of multiple factors
it the fact that there was a need for it
at the time and also being open and it's
just reasonably good code as well and
that's important too and you know and it
kind of build its community that way
starting from those two companies and
like two products working on it and so
parque is a disk-based columnar format
and 40 we want to build on that success
and enable an memory-based come not from
it okay so the goal is to share the
effort create an ecosystem so it's just
like not have one group of people build
all the integrations because then they
can happen in parallel in all of those
teams and also you know create the
ecosystem because then once you reach a
critical mass then like it becomes
natural things right we just everybody
is going to reuse it and so it's really
important to be start up from the start
and you know we'll be all these
consensus and make sure to be inclusive
but also be able to keep things simple
and not have too many things in it so
for the Apache arrow project we started
by it includes pmc members from all
those projects not all those projects
are Apache project but most are so in
the PMC for if you not familiar with how
Apache works the PMC in the project
management committee so basically the
people on the PMC they can decide who is
going to become a commuter
there's a vote you like this person is
worthy or like as proven that they
provide good contribution of they have
good input and we want to make them a
cometer and/or new pmc members so it's
kind of like the root people who ever
see hey how do we build that community
and then when you're a committer your
main responsibility is getting other
people's code in it in the in the source
in the code base so we started by making
sure we evolved people from all those
project which are you can see storage
layers like like kudu or HBase or
Cassandra or more execution engine like
drill Impala spark storm and are in
pandas on the Python time so this was
really important to make sure we kind of
include feedback from these people and
make sure we get on an agreement on the
format and Anibal things and the reason
these people got together it's not just
because hey let's have a beer or
something right because there's the the
world in memory columnar representation
is coming from research so if you look
at the Monet DB papers and the state of
the art of database execution this is
where all those core execution is going
to go faster so and I'll go in the
details of why columnar it's faster and
so those are a few quotes you have to
read them but basically taking from
values project and and they are
basically stating how they moving to
columnar so which is it's not the
project that's driving moving people
moving to columnar it's actually all
those corian genes are moving to
columnar execution to vectorize the
execution because it goes faster and the
idea of the project a wait a minute if
we can agree on the format the in-memory
representation there are a lot of
benefits coming from having a common
standard or presentation and I'll go in
the details of that so you've seen that
similar presentation in the West slides
earlier about arrow
so before you know every integration
requires a we need a custom integration
between those two projects we need a
ization this organization we need to
agree on what the common protocol or
format is going to be and that's a lot
of duplication of effort and you know
they all have different bags on the
other end if we agree on what the format
is when the handshake is all that stuff
then it becomes much simpler things and
once you integrate it with the standard
then you integrate with everybody who
integrates a standard and so an
important part is to agree on a certain
what are the specifics of the format
because it's not just it's not just
standard it has to be efficient for that
particular task of doing data analytics
and so one of the key things is when you
do all those integrations often you have
formats in between two systems that are
the lowest common denominator right it's
just whatever is in common like when you
do Python to Java and there's a lot of
overhead of sterilization disser ization
like currently in PI spark there's a lot
of overhead in sending the data across
processes and converting from one to the
other but if we agree on the format and
it's in the in-memory representation
then there's no circulation
disorganisation when you just share the
memory it's much more efficient and so
that's where I'm going to go into
details of what is an efficient
representation in memory for data
analytics and that's where it's based on
all the vectorization vectorized
execution research and you can lock look
up things like monet DB and such so I
took a little bit about Connor formats
sorry I'm very old-school my gif is not
animated I don't know if the presenter
from BuzzFeed is here but that was
pretty cool animated gif
so you know culinary art 101 so when we
think of a table so you have a table
here it's two-dimensional but we are
going to put it on a binary media that
is one-dimensional right whether you put
it on this car in memory it's a list of
values right it's one-dimensional so
you're going to have to put it either
one row at a time or one column at a
time so traditionally is a simple way of
doing it you put it one row at a time
and you actually interleave values from
different columns so let's say if column
a is a strain calling b is an int and
Colin C is a date you're going to
interleave a string and int that string
I need that date and if you do column
now representation well you're going to
put all the strings together all the
integers together and all the dates
together and then brings a lot of room
for optimizations because let's say you
say so know something about your
integers that they are smaller than 10
for example then that means you actually
need five bits to encode each integers
right and because you encode a bunch of
integers together you can just stir them
is a much more compact way but if you
interleave strings and ins and things
then becomes much harder to interleave
things because you put a string and you
have something that takes a few bit and
maybe you put a date that has different
characteristic behind and also when you
use a compression like more brute force
compression algorithm like snappy or lgo
or Jesus or whatever your favorite
compression is also going to be more
efficient because you put together all
the things that are similar right so
it's going to work better just because
you put together things and then when
you access data is going to be much more
efficient because when you cook when you
create it so here i have three columns
but typically you have dozens hundreds
of columns maybe thousands if you're
crazy you see that
and but usually when you query the data
you access only a subset of the columns
so that's where when you read only let's
say column B it's going to be much more
efficient to go to the column B you read
all the B's and not even look at the
other ones when in the first case you
would rain the first be do a small seek
do is read the second B and so on right
you do a lot of cigs and adds up
scanning the data it's relatively almost
the same as reading everything right you
can't really make it faster by reading
only the tiny bit you need but if you
access a big like a range at a time only
the bees then it's going to be a lot
more efficient so another aspect so
probably some people will think hey why
didn't you just put back in memory why
did you need another format well the
trade trade are far different right the
design decisions have slightly different
trade-offs when you're on disk its
storage you're writing once and you're
doing to going to do a lot of queries on
it and there's a priority to I your
addiction you want to reduce I owe more
than you want to reduce CPU it still has
to be fast right if it's to CPU angry
then it's not going to work but you want
to reduce I owe more than cpu and it's
going to be mostly streaming access so
you're doing scans on a lot of data in
memory it's more transient right it's
being materialized for specific tasks so
it could be executing the query could be
doing something else but you load it
once in memory you do what you have to
do with it and then you throw it away so
there's less of this pattern of we
accessing a subset of the column and the
priority will be much more to CPU stupid
because we're in memory right so we are
not there's less of this I or bottleneck
of accessing persistent storage and
there are also a lot more use cases when
you actually need random access and
being able to access individual records
in constant time so a little bit about
the details of parquet so parking
support nested data structure it's a
compact format
it has type of wear and coatings like
big packing or dictionary encoding which
basically because when you we know the
type of each columns we can use a much
better encodings to compress that in a
very efficient way if you think of
dictionary encoding it's replacing every
value with an ID and int coming from a
dictionary you built up all the distinct
values so if you have a reasonably small
cardinality on this column the small
number of distinct values then you're
going to be able to compress a lot and
using very little CPU because then
decompression is just a look up in a
table that is indexed right is Charlie
give me the ID the value for this ID and
it's constant time access so it's
extremely it's good at compressing and
it's extremely fast decoding compared to
a more brute force algorithm like jeezy
that takes a bunch of bytes and tries to
find repetition in it without knowing
anything about record boundaries or
things like that and it also does
optimize I oh so projection push down
and featuring push down projection push
down is I want only those columns I need
and filter push down is based on
statistics so the the files in sarnia
partitions in raw group or groups and we
keep statistics of min max fried chicken
and / or group so when you access the
data you can really access the goal is
to minimize I owe to the minimum to
minimize I you to only what you need and
so you know projection push down we keep
only the comment we we want statistics
provide predicates push down feature
programs and you can keep only rose or
at least partitions of rows then you
want using min max so especially if you
did I sorted it's going to be very
efficient and then you read only the
data you need and I cheated a little bit
because I told you parkash apartness to
data structures and I add only examples
with flat data structures so if you want
to read the details of how parquet
converts knitted st data structure in
the flat columnar representation
this blog post I wrote with all the
details and the general idea idea is if
you want to store nulls you would use
one bit find value for each value saying
is it none or is it defined and so the
way you store nesting is instead of
storing just one bit you will store an
integers which says at which level in
the tree it is now because obviously if
one level is a journey is now then
everything below is not as well so just
at one depth for each column is it now
is enough to keep information of whether
the feeling is not at what level and
because those are small integers we can
use the beat packing trick I was talking
about before and it's very small
information so a little bit about arrow
now so similar ID arrow is well
documented format from the beginning
meaning it's not the spec is not defined
by you provide the name of the java
class to use and that's your spec and if
you want to know what the actual binary
format you look at the code it's
actually well defined and the goal is is
cross-language compatible you have a c++
implementation you have a java
implementation for accessing and the
purpose of that is just like parquet can
be read by Impala or C++ and written by
other C++ systems or Java in the oil
interoperable and that way you open up
all of your options right you can read
packet from Python you can write it from
Python and you can read it from spark or
drill or your favorite java-based
psychology so same idea for arrow it's
designed to take advantage of modern CPU
characteristics that I'm going to go in
the detail of that and it's available in
execution engine storage layers etc and
the goal is to make all those so things
interoperable easily
and just like parquet its supports and
st data structures in a different way
because it's optimized for a random
access as well and we'll go in the
details of what pipelining cindy and
cash flow cali how they work in the
modern CPUs and why it's important and
they enable scatter gather io because
the ID because we standardize an
in-memory representation when you send
over the wire on the network your data
structures you can just tell the network
interface a grab those buffers look
there's column a here columbia here come
see here put all those things on the
network and it's just going to directly
send those buffers to the network and on
the other side you can say a texas
buffers put them in memory and you have
a little bit of metadata around to say
hey the length of the buffers and
there's no serialization deserialization
all you're doing is sending your buffers
on the wire reading them back in memory
there's no transformation that is CPU
angry like you know what happens when
you use your language serialization
deserialization like turning into java
objects of python objects right because
the roll binary representation in memory
is the same as on the wire and that's
very important because a lot of the time
is spent in series asian dissertation in
cpu so pipelining if you think of I'm
talking about modern CPUs so we think of
CPUs processors as executing one
instruction after the other and it's not
been working like that for a long time
what superiors are doing they're trying
to because you know same thing a
processor is an area with different
parts in it right and when you're using
part of it another part of it could be
doing something else so it can actually
do some things in parallel but still
clogged base of doing things one after
the other so what it's doing its trying
to it starts the next instruction before
the previous one is finished so
executing an instruction is split in a
pipeline
and it goes through different steps of
that pipeline so here I have an
imaginary four-step pipeline I think
it's more like a dozen steps it depends
a lot on what Frost authority is and so
if it's starting the next instruction
before the previous one is finished
there are different things that can
happen so what next instruction to
execute could depend on the previous
execution being finished let like thank
you even if this is true then do that
otherwise do this or loop which
basically is my loop done and I continue
below or I go back to the beginning of
the loop and do again or if you have a
virtual call like you have a function
and depending on the type of the object
and calling the function on going to
jump to a different place so those are
all things that are data dependent right
what I'm going to do depends on
something to be executed before so what
the CPU has there's a branch prediction
mechanism it says hey I'm going to try
to guess what the next instruction is
because I don't know yet because I have
to wait for this one to be finished i'm
going to start executing that one that i
guessed if i'm right well we saved a lot
of time if i'm wrong well as throw the
what I've done way and I'll start over
and that's what school is called a
bubble in the pipeline and so when
you're right you know you get maximum
throughput from you CPUs it's actually
doing 10 times as many instruction as
otherwise and when you're wrong well you
know you lose that many cycles of having
to start over so the main idea
vectorized execution is because you
organized data one column at a time
instead of one row at a time when you
evaluate an expression and when you do
something you treat all the values for
one column at a time which means you're
doing you're going to do the same exact
same instruction or small set of
instruction in a tight loop that's going
to do the same thing over and over with
no of your own codes what you want to
avoid like typically where you have an
expression you're evaluating you're
doing a plus B plus C divided by D you
know something else each of the plus R
divided it's actually an eval method
right with a virtual call which means
that sometimes you do plus for the same
call sometime you divide it and like the
branch predictor is actually not that
smart right and so it's going to be
wrong all the time and you get like
terrible performance but if you do the
exact same thing if you let's say let's
do all the a plus B first and so what
you're going to do you're going to do a
plus B in a tight loop which is always
always always the same thing and the
branch prediction is going to be always
right yeah we're just doing the same
loop again yeah except for the last time
I hope the loop is finished I was wrong
but you know it's negligible across the
60,000 execution you just did so that's
where vectorized execution is a lot more
efficient because it avoid a lot of
bubbles and can get the most stupid of
the cpu so that the main idea behind
vectorized execution and keeping data in
columns another aspect is CPU cache so
you know memory is in your RAM your main
memory and the CPU is separate and the
CPU can go really fast but it's going
much faster than getting data across the
bus so to resolve that just like CPUs
have a branch predictor to kind of cheat
and go faster than the shoot they have
memory cache on the CPU that much faster
to access but much smaller so they will
keep memory around data run that they're
just working on and that goes much
faster but the trick is of course it's
much smaller so if you're accessing a
lot of data that is in different place
there's a lot of cash thrashing right
you keep accessing data sets somewhere
else and you keep sending data on and
off the cash right and you wait
something the CP we wait every time I'm
depending on this data it's not in my
cash I need to wait for it to arrive it
takes many cycles and then I can work on
it so in the victor eyes execution mode
because you're working set is much
smaller and you work on one column at a
time you can be a lot more efficient
because instead of having a
ABC ABC for all the columns and then you
read a and then you read the other a and
then your ad all right you have more
data in it that you may not be using
right away and you can put less of your
working set in your cash if you're
walking on all the a and b's and they're
together then you can be a lot faster
because you're going to load only the
thing in your cash and the cash would be
more efficient right and you do you have
more cash locality and you do less up
going back and forth on the bus with the
cpu and so that's just amazing crash
locality the other thing i haven't
mentioned is modern CPUs now have seen
the instruction so it stands for single
instruction multiple data and you can
tell the CPU hey instead of doing a plus
B here are 4 a's here are four B's do a
plus B on all those four values and
start those four results in this place
so you get actually four times this
Rupert and that's actually it works only
if you have the columnar data
representation right you put all the
data next to each other in memory and
you're telling the cpu Duke the exact
same instruction four times so in one
cycle is doing is going to do 4 plusses
and you get more of this so it's another
trick that modern CPUs do to go faster
and that is enabled by vectorized
execution ok so those are more details
about how its represented and I'll go a
little faster in it in on this part
because I've been a little too slow on
the first part but so it's more about
details of how the representation is and
so you know you start with the schema
negotiation here's the schema is going
to tell you what Colin exists what
vector exists and then when you treat
the data it's splitting record batches
write because usually you don't need you
won't don't want to fit all the data set
in memory you can have one chunk at a
time and then you have all those batches
that can be received one after another
that all have the same schema so if you
look at it if you have this
Jason example right there that's right
column name age phones so we can look at
H first because it's a fixed-width type
and for simplicity I don't represent
mouths in this example nulls are
represented with a bit set right one bit
per value and so if it's fixed with
types you see here you know it's just a
vector and you have that number of bytes
for each value and you have dry access /
the index of the value the age for the
first record is the first value the age
for the second record is the second
value and it's fixed width so it's easy
random access it's a variable when lens
like name name is a string it's a
variable lance and you have a vector for
the upset and each value is a
starting-off set of the string and the
next values is the end up set right I'd
starting upset of the next string that's
why it has an extra value that points at
the end is just a simplification so that
in the code you can always assume that
the next value points to the end of your
string so there's always an extra offset
which is where we'd start the next value
of their words one and if you have a
list basically you can reuse this is
composable right for storing list it's
the same mechanism at storing variable
with types basically we have an upset
vector that point so this is composable
right you can make a list of lists of
lists of lists just add more obsessed
vectors and you can access any value in
constant time I mean it's constant to
the scheme is dependent on the depths of
the schema it's proportional to the
depths of the schema because you were
one look up or list in your schema but
it's basically a constant time for
otherwise and so when you send the
record on the wire on the network you
would put the data header that tells you
here's the buffers here the lens and
they just sent one after each other on
the wire which means you can just tell
the network level to say a copy those
buffers to the wire and that's all there
is there's no extra transformation
and so in RPC to avoid sterilization
distillation so all the hover head which
can be quite important observation
dissertation is gone and for internal
process communication you can share this
data you can remove entirely the copy as
well because since you're creating an
immutable record batch right once you
finish running a record batch you get
say it's immutable you can share it as
read only memory and and then the next
process can read it and produce a new
record badge so there's also a memory
management component because it's all in
memory so just being able to define
hodad's and saying the keeping track of
what part of the code is using how much
memory it'll view of language bindings
so parquet as java cpp python pandas
integration arrow as well as West
mentioned the our integration maybe it's
more a put it under way here but I think
it's pretty advanced Park a and gene
integration there are a lot of things at
sport bar k for arrow which is newer
apache trail is a query engine that
supports it pandas are supported there's
some work being done to integrate to
spar and one of the holy grail is you
know when you have pi spark is to have
the zero overhead interaction between pi
spark and arrow and so some examples on
how that work so if you want
distributive execution that's an example
of how you do some from something group
by something else and so you know the
way it works in a distributed way you do
partial aggregations and then it's
consistently hashed to send you know the
same keys to the same machine and then
once you've done your partial
aggregation you send them over finish
your aggregation send it to the user and
so the main key the key here is once you
finish writing your partial bag there's
no serialization disorganization
involved just plain copy to the next one
and same thing for collecting the data
to the user and because it's
column-oriented you can do all the
vectorize much more efficient processing
and so in the Python use case like you
can imagine like let's say you have a
sequel engine and you want to use your
Python UD apps ugf standing for
user-defined function and so right now
some use case for pi spark is there some
deserving serialization disorganization
involved so with this because we're
using the exact representation and
because it is the efficient
representation for vectorized execution
of the core engine it can just the
quarry engine materialize input to the
functions it will share that memory
let's say you have a java quarry engines
like sparks equal or drill it can share
this memory with a Python project
partner Python process bison process
will read the input produce the output
as an immutable data structure and that
can bring right by the next operator and
that's a lot more efficient there's no
override there's no copy there's no
serious issue in this realization
there's no copy because the data is just
shared in memory in between processes
and because it's immutable there's no
problem with sharing it you can even
share it with multiple processes there's
no modification in happening so now just
a little bit of summarization this is a
typical what are the latency is you know
you've seen that slides before I'm sure
and you can see the cache CPU cache and
you have multiple level of caching
branch misprediction main memory
reference and then in the future thing
that you get starts happy seeing
happening is nvme which is non-volatile
memory and when we talk about
non-volatile memory is basically flash
inside of your memory slots and it's not
for us it's not really that it's
persistent storage at ortant it's more
that it's a layer is cheaper than
regular memory and you can get a lot
more for the same price and it's not too
much lower so it's slower than regular
memory but it's cheaper so it's just
like some kind of different trade-off
because remember all those coin and
jeans is trying to do as much as
possible in memory because it's faster
but when it doesn't fit in memory than
they have to spill to disk and fall back
to disk and so as long as your data set
fits in memory is ready fast and then it
doesn't fit any more than becomes really
slow so the main idea is to say hey
those are new technologies that get in
the middle and then enable more options
right instead of falling from very fast
or slow we have some other options in
the middle when you can put a lot more
design it it's slower than main memory
but it's much faster than disk so that's
what non-volatile memory is about 3d
x-point crosspoint is the Intel new
flash drive it's like very fast flash
drives so it's like another in between
RDMA is remote direct memory read and
that's like you have new technologies
coming which enables you to read memory
from a remote machines without going
through its CPU so you can say I want to
read this data from this memory and you
don't use its CPU at all so you can see
in those immutable data structures
that's very interesting because as soon
if the host machine shares information
of where certain data sets are located
another machines can read it remotely
and doing scans and doing other
operation with limited load on the host
memory ln x re on the whole cpu and then
enables so that's future right that's
the kind of stuff that's coming in term
of technologies and that will enable
those clusters working in reducing the
use of the CPU and freeing it for other
things and of course at the bottom you
have the spinning disk so SSDs and
spinning disk and you cannot see like
which we are trying to do you have a lot
of trade-offs and compromise you can do
between all those things
so sorry I'm earning a little overtime
so I'm going to skip those example is
just you know similar idea how you
extract data from each base Cassandra
could you using arrow and making a lot
more efficient just for the short story
currently kudu when it you could you can
do projection push down feature push
down very well and any present rose it
will assemble rose on the server side
and send them to the client because
typically current clients are oriented
but when you presented the drill
integration for example right now it
will ask you to do the push downs for
projection filtering and we get those
rows and then it will convert them back
in and column representation so once we
have the arrow integration who do can
materialize arrow columns send them on
over the wires and first kudu will be
much more efficient than generating
columns and rows because kudu is
column-oriented so it can do the
vectorized way of generating those
columns which is going to be much faster
than sm being rose and doing a lot of
back and forth in memory and second then
on the client-side drill we just work
directly from those columns because it's
already its internal representation for
data so you skip a lot of CPU last doing
conversions from one format to the other
because we lack of this standard in
memory format for analytics so this is
all happening so we had the step where
the format is defined and you know it's
available in C++ in Java and starts
being integrated in value things at
different rates so you start seeing it
more and more available in various
things and you're welcome to contribute
as well or to push your favorite open
source project to adopt it faster and
similar thing you could do an in-memory
cache based on that this is an
illustration of the cheering you know
like I was saying you try to work out of
memory because it's much faster when it
doesn't work we fall back to disk and
the I stored in disk like in packet
format for example and non-volatile
memory can is trade-off when
you can you know have something in
between so that you don't have all the
performance it's not like either fast or
slow you can have a more range for
different different for different use
cases you know like throughput goes up
cuts goes down and it's kind of like the
future like you see more and more C's DS
or nvme which is basically you know
splash in your demon it's not the many
more so as I said we have support for
the park a C++ center or C++ RK c plus
plus I've integration with Python and
they have a flat integration so we need
support from nested data structures
we've been working on IPC implementation
which is defining what's the protocol
for sharing that for having this
read-only shared memory you know thanks
to do integration adding this Python UDF
use case which will be enabled by IPC so
working on having this better by spark
integration when you can like West
presented if you've seen the Python
presentation from Wes you can use arrow
data frame in pandas so you can write
pandas functions then you can use in
price part but removing all the overhead
of serializing deserializing when going
from spark to python so now it's going
to be much faster because right now data
scientists they use python and it's
really fast you can use pandas can do
really fast things and then when you
move to distributed mode then it goes a
lot slower because you have all the
overhead of service asian
disorganisation sending over the network
and so it's about removing all this
overhead and making it a lot faster
right and so if you want to join the
community learn more about it you have a
mailing list for arrow and parky Apache
project there's a slack for arrow so
this URL you know slides you need to be
vided so this URL enables you to put
your emails to get Auto invited and join
the arrow slack the Apache project URL
and we're on Twitter as well you can
follow tweet and stop thank you